One of the striking features of human
female reproduction is menstruation.
It's uncomfortable.
It's sometimes painful.
Why did it evolve?
There are four hypotheses.
One is that the evolve to
eliminate parasites introduced
with copulation evolve
to save energy.
Yeah.
Or it may have evolved to protect the
uterus from inflammation or is a byproduct
of maternal fetal conflict.
Yeah.
Here are those major hypotheses sketched
out on a bit more detail and I'd like
to make a few comments about them.
The first one is the menstruation
evolved to get rid of pathogens that were
brought in with a sperm and so the
claim is that is protecting the uterus
against colonization by pathogens.
The problem is that menstruation occurs
weeks after copulation and this problem
of having sperm borne pathogens is
not unique to species. That ministry,
there are many species that
don't menstruate that would
have the same problem.
The second idea is that
menstruating conserves energy
and the administration and
resorption is energetically less costly
than maintaining a differentiated
endometrium.
However,
maintaining a differentiated
differentiated endometrium
is not the alternative
and other species.
It also would not allow for Avi Elation
or sperm transport or sperm capacitation.
So a third hypothesis is that
menstruation is actually not adaptive.
It is a consequence of
spontaneous decidual lization.
So the real issue then becomes spontaneous
decision realization and we'll go
into that in a minute to
explain exactly what that is.
Now that is consistent with known con
known consequences if does of decidual
lization and uh,
in the paper we're allying all on this
is the argument that the authors were
making.
So the problem then is to explain why
decidual ization became spontaneous.
A fourth possibility is that the uterus
is being preconditioned by menstruation
and that is protecting uterine tissues
from hyper inflammation and from
oxidative stress that are associated
with deep placentation in humans with the
deep,
deep invasiveness of plantation.
Okay.
So this claim ignores why ministration
may have evolved in ancestral primate
species and administrating non primates
that don't have the deep invasion.
Yeah.
And it may ignore the benefits that
spontaneous decision realization might
provide.
So what we're going to do is we're going
to really focus on spontaneous decidual
ization
okay.
First a bit of a refresher
on the human menstrual cycle.
It has a follicular phase
and the luteal in the ovary.
During the follicular phase, the
follicles mature. During the luteal phase,
the Corpus luteum is
secreting progesterone.
What that does in the uterus is
that in the proliferative phase,
the superficial endometrium is
shed and flip operation begins.
Then in the luteal phase,
that's the secretory phase where the
endometrium continues to deliver to
differentiate and proliferate.
The hormone levels in the follicular phase
are dominated by estrodial all and in
the luteal phase by progesterone,
menstruation starts on day one.
So that's the follicular phase.
[inaudible] occurs on day 14.
And then decision realization begins.
So decidual ization is the transformation
of the endometrium stimulated by
progesterone under maternal control to
prepare it to receive the implanting
embryo when for gesture
or own is withdrawn.
The differentiated endometrial stromal
cells undergo apoptosis and that leads to
menstruation.
We know that ministration
evolved three times.
It's indicated here in red,
and
that includes the primates over here,
some bats,
and interestingly the elephant shrews.
So other things that ministry include
chimpanzees and givens and uh,
orangutans and mechanics
and some of the monkeys,
as well as several bats.
And the elephant. Shrew.
What features do these organisms share?
They all have spontaneous
decision realization.
They have invasive Hema
Correale presentation.
They have extended meeting periods.
They have spontaneous ovulation.
That means Oblation,
which is not induced by meeting itself.
Okay.
And they have one or two
well-developed offspring per pregnancy.
So they have a few,
we'll develop relatively
large offspring per pregnancy.
So the three groups in
which menstruation occurs,
all have hemo Correale Placentas,
menstruation is here in red.
So here is, uh, the elephant shrew.
You are humans and here are
the free tail vats. Okay.
So they all have hemo Correale placentas,
highly invasive placentas.
Okay.
The real issue appears to be
spontaneous decision realization.
So in mammals that don't menstruate,
decidual [inaudible] occurs when the
embryo implants in mammals that men's
straight decidual lization is spontaneous.
That means that it's under maternal
control and it occurs independently of the
presence of an embryo.
So why did it evolve?
Yeah.
Well,
one hypothesis is that it's a maternal
response that protects the mother from
the invasive embryo.
Another hypothesis is
that it's a mechanism that
allows the mother to discard
defective embryos.
These are not mutually exclusive.
So if you have spontaneous decision
realization administration,
it is one way of flushing a defective
embryo out of the female reproductive
tract.
Yeah.
We know that there are other features
of quality control built into the female
reproductive tract. There is a treasure
and they're spontaneous abortions.
Yeah.
Oh, city Katriza starts about the third
month of pregnancy. At that point,
there are about 7 million oh sites
in the newly formed ovaries by birth.
There are about a million
by men are about a thousand.
And by menopause they're nearly none left.
So a Trecia does seem to target both
nuclear and mitochondrial mutations and it
appears that there's at least a tendency
for the damaged eggs to be eliminated
and the less damaged eggs to be kept.
Yeah.
Spontaneous abortions or miscarriages
are relatively frequent estimates of the
proportion of pregnancies that ended in
early unrecognized abortion range from
30 to 75% clinically
recognized pregnancies,
character, uh, miscarry, and
about 10 to 20% of cases,
most of which have
chromosomal abnormalities.
About 70% of gestations diagnosed with
ultrasound is twins are singletons when
they are delivered.
So in all of these cases,
there is some kind of selections it's
going on in the reproductive tract.
Prior to birth,
spontaneous abortion may function to
both eliminate defective embryos and to
reduce the reproductive cost of twins.
So to summarize,
ministration evolved at
least three times in mammals,
always in lineages that
have invasive placentation,
it appears to be a byproduct of
adaptations to protect the mother in fetal
maternal conflict.
It may also have evolved as
a quality control mechanism,
and the key mechanism is decidual
lization that is spontaneous rather than
triggered by meeting.